désamorcer les tensions méditerranée
orientale
tel est l'objectif de la tournée express
du chef de la diplomatie allemande et
heiko maas en visite aujourd'hui en
grèce et en turquie les deux pays qui se
disputent l'exploitation de cette zone
riche en hydrocarbures
la découverte d'importants gisements
gaziers dans ces eaux a en effet égalisé
l'appétit des pays riverains expédition
navale discours martial et déploiements
militaires les démonstrations de force
entre les deux pays membres de l'otan se
multiplient
l'allemagne essaie donc de jouer les
médiateurs pour favoriser l'émergence
d'un accord à l'amiable entre les deux
puissances
il est nécessaire que l'allemagne reste
en dialogue avec les deux parties car
l'objectif est que la grèce et la
turquie
résolvez leurs différents directement
l'une avec l'autre
heiko maas doit ainsi rencontrer son
homologue grec nikos dendias ce ainsi
que le premier ministre
kyriakos minnesota keith avant de se
rendre en turquie pour rencontrer le
chef de la diplomatie mevlüt cavusoglu
l'objectif trouver un compromis pour
préserver la stabilité dans la région
toutes initiatives entreprises par
l'allemagne en tant que grande puissance
en europe aura une importance
particulière
mais il faut que ses interlocuteurs
soient fiables il faut que la turquie
prouve sa crédibilité
de son côté la france a renforcé sa
présence militaire en méditerranée
orientale
une démonstration de force agaçante pour
ankara qui accuse paris de jeter l'huile
sur le feu
la politique française plus offensive
n'a pas trouvé de résonance du côté de
son binôme allemand qui préfèrent une
position de médiateur pour mieux faire
baisser les tensions et toujours
concernant ces tensions méditerranée
orientale le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan a accusé la grèce de mettre en
danger la navigation dans ces eaux une
déclaration après l'annoncé des
autorités grecques d'exercices
militaires dans la zone écouter la grèce
n'a pas le droit d'émettre un tel navtex
dans la région cette annonce est un acte
capricieux qui met en danger la sécurité
de la navigation et des côtes pour tous
les navires dans la région
avec cette approche contraire au droit
international à la bonne volonté et aux
relations de bon voisinage
la grèce se jette dans un chaos dont
elle ne peut sortir
désormais la grèce sera responsable de
tous les développements négatifs qui
pourrait avoir lieu dans la région et
elle sera le seul pays à subir des
dommages